on this week's show is the buy-to-let
market dead in the news we reveal which
city has capped any further rent
increases over the next five years and
we're gonna managing all your property
related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends
I almost lids I'm Alistair Cunningham
and welcome to this week's property
investors podcast interesting yeah I
mean for me when I first got into
property vital X was where it was that
and then and then it kind of advanced on
to other things like HMO service
combination Hobie finance but it all
started for me with buy-to-let so a lot
of people are saying bye to let's add
ads now yeah a lot people are so we're
gonna be discussing that later
before we get cracking into that tell us
about your what you've been up to in the
exciting just events so we had a cup of
crash courses but you've been really
good really do you know what last crash
course was really good
and it was a very intimate room I was
one about 250 people there but it was a
buzzing room buzzing room so yes very
very good what itself oh I'm into
theater okay what are you gonna see I
went to see The Only Fools and Horses
see that was a good it's very good very
very good I want to go and see but I'm
trying to work out how do we do it like
how whose was it was they all boys Dale
boy and he like it's very difficult to
for somebody played the oh boy yeah how
did that come back I think that they did
a really good job it a really good job
of creating the characters you know they
had some of you know some of the they
sounded a bit like they were obviously
from step when you actually look at the
photos they look nothing like the guy
looks nothing like Dale boy but but
because it's on stage and you're a
little bit distance away and they're
wearing the same to Del Boy currently
our boy can all that it kind of looked
it was really good though it's basically
like a very long episode with with bits
they put together an episode by taking
bits of the series season the series and
put it together into a store in its own
right
but it's great really good highly
recommend it and I used an app to buy
the ticket so you guys might find this
interesting if you're in London wanting
West End tickets Hamlet Royal Circle it
wasn't like the best seats in the house
it was DC decent very very decent seats
at a really good view and I picked ones
right on on the end so I had no one next
movie chart which I like I always do
that yeah and also if you need to get up
and go to the bathroom or when you've
got that problem I'm sorry no trying
that cupcake right but there's a an app
called todaytix okay and have a guess
how much it cost me using todaytix to
get two tickets
50p how much was that was it it was
twenty five pretty ticket
how much did normally I don't know but
more 35 is cheaper really be interested
2012 cheap it's cheap but it's not that
much that expensive acted on the website
I think I think it was meant to be about
for the tea you can get cheaper tickets
buy a decent seat it's meant to be about
38 anyway that's a good point your grand
socco sauce good yeah like you enjoyed
them why'd you do it so I'll have to see
yeah you should I love Only Fools and
Horses I saw its classic all-time
classic isn't it and even in ten years
we'll still be watching it and 20 years
we'll still be watching it
well it's before my time really can't
did the series finished it's like an 80s
show yeah it's more your sort of time
but I still relate to it even though I
wasn't born you know George I knew
that's where you were going as soon as
you said it's Kanan before my time so
anyway is the buy too late market dead
what's your take on it um very very good
question very Western he's the buyer at
market dead I would say no yeah I would
say no as well and it's not dead it's
just different so like they were seeing
the bottom
late markets dead in 2008 2009 there was
people say or not because things are
changing obviously the big recession but
there's more wealthy people since then
and they have ever been so I don't for
one minute
the biotech markets dead I think all
you've got to do it you've got to
strategize you've got to be very
creative and you've got to treat it like
a business I think if you're stuck in
your old ways of like going to a high
street lend or financing it that way and
doing it completely sort of safe shall
we say then yeah maybe perhaps the
margins are not as big as they used to
be okay what the arguments you say that
the people think what
why would somebody even say is both let
dead what are the what a lot of the
things that I'm seeing a lot of people
criticizing a lot of the media of so the
new rule changes with tax section 24
things that are so we did a show if we
could put a link if we could put a link
in Nick we we did an episode talking
about the tax changes and the
implications with you know interest on
your mortgage and yeah and all that sort
of stuff okay so just to recap what is
section 24 for those that aren't so
section 24 is the rules that came in
that meant that you couldn't offset the
the interest payments on your mortgage
you couldn't claim that as a
tax-deductible expense yes okay so
basically meant that for the first time
ever you could actually have to pay more
tax than you are actually making in
profit yeah it's interesting because I
speak to a lot of landlords and I know
quite a few landlords that are sort of
accidental accidental landlords so
they've inherited or they've just you
know back in the 80s 90s they bought a
couple of properties and they're just
they're just running along as as a
landlord we position I'm so perfectly as
well they're just running along as a
landlord and making a little bit of
money every month with a new rule
changes it means that a little bit money
is now even less if not negative mmm and
it's crazy that some I know a landlord
for instance that the owns are a four
hundred thousand pound house and it's
actually costing their money because
they of course it's just ridiculous it's
costing their money intact and they're
looking to offload and the thing is
there are the damned damned if you do
damned if you don't
if the sale they're going to get all
sorts of taxes if it don't sell they
wouldn't get hit with income tax and
they can't offset the mortgage payments
and if you try and put them into a
limited company they're gonna get taxed
and also it's ridiculous I'm sure
there's ways around that but you need to
beat your accountant there is ways
around it you can buy through a
a limited company this is not the show
talk about that about that watch live
show but yes you got problem we've got
problems like that yeah uh I mean the
good thing about buy-to-let when you
compare it to HHM owns some
accommodation and everything is that
it's much easier to much easier to
manage
yeah so for even if you're not managing
it you know there's a case of you you
have to manage the manager don't you -
if you've got like a HMO manager in
place you even though they're the one
that's who's ultimately responsible you
are your landlord you're the one that's
names on it you're the ones on the EST
contract it's your responsibility is yes
fundamentally it's gonna be you in court
if something goes wrong so they have
problems if they avoid it whatever it is
well obviously that's the it falls on
you with a buy-to-let it's it's much
easier you know you know you don't have
to find a specialist any anyone any sort
of high street letting agents that's
what they couldn't rent out a property
you'd like to think you'd like you know
there's a lot of very incompetent land
agent you would like and from my
experience they do yeah in my experience
they do so I think the lessons here look
if you're old school and you've
inherited a couple properties or you've
just happened to acquire a few
properties over your time and because
fundamentally investment is still
property investing will always make
money fundamentally over time absolutely
but if you've if you like let's just say
you're you're an old school investor for
instance you're very stuck in your own
ways you've got a couple of properties
that you're just renting out as a single
light basis and now you've been hit
massively by changes by rules get
creative
like maybe can you use them same
properties and get more money from them
so could um for instance run them our
service accommodation or run Amma's HMO
or hold a layoff or whatever and just
just get a little bit creative and awful
well maybe but what what I'm trying to
get at is every property should have
more than one exit strategy so if you're
if you're only exit strategy as a
single-leg property then maybe you start
looking looking at it and so I think the
lessons here are when you're buying make
sure you've got multiple exits
if it won't work as a single lip because
you're not gonna make enough money
because the rule changes could it be
running as HM all
I'll keep it runs a service condition do
you not mean so just just get creative
or how you're doing things I think as
long as you as long as you know what
you're doing when you go into it I think
where they were really unfair
is and again is again they tend to
target the amateur investors does their
tar and make it difficult for them so as
long as you know what you're doing is
like why did they do that
I wonder why is it they do it why is it
the establishment the government the
bank's everybody whoever makes these
rules why is that they always seem to
target the this this the small guy who's
got two or three properties or he's got
a small business why it's the same as
wider wider wider the government targets
small business owners yeah you know it's
like it's a case of you more money you
earn the more tax you pay yeah till you
get to a certain level very reverse is
that they're they're targeting the the
every day because a few reason there's a
lot more of them yeah and number two
never get because they don't know what
they're doing yeah a professional will
look at it and change it and the
professionals will move their times yeah
so they're just targeting people that
don't know what they're doing cuz
they're an easy target and I'm there's a
less and you just gotta be flexible and
move of the times always oh I think
you've got to always be looking at what
the markets are doing what rule changes
are coming out what's going to affect
your business because let's face it if
you're a property investor you should be
treating this like a business not like a
site hustles and treat it like a
business act like a business treat it
like it's are a high street retail shop
if suddenly there's a lot of changes
come in you move and you be fluid so
that you can avoid them impacts and
avoid them hits particularly to move on
particular easy to make that mistake on
someone that's giving you a passive
income because in your head is this is
passive only and they ignore it
hands-off no it's fine carry on carry on
with businesses like blockbuster yes
you know blockbuster I had the chance to
buy Netflix didn't take it I'm like no
we will stick with our suit of our video
shops thank you very much yeah because
they didn't move at the times I mean the
world right now is changing faster so
quickly than ever change more in history
yeah so there's any time where you need
to be adaptable you need to stick to
change you need to be making moves
and going with the flow it's now whether
that's property whether that's business
whether that's whatever it is move with
the techniques move all the time
take a look into this right so for
instance 10 years ago rent to rent was
not even a thing well I think it was a
thing there isn't not many people knew
about it come on not like it is today
service combination was not a thing
like nobody was doing it or very very it
wasn't thing again just was it was a
thing it just was think about it holiday
let's it's extension of that yeah but
not the way we see it today the way we
see it today it's grown a lot screwing
massive and it's no the thing if 10
years ago if you were looking to go away
on business
you wouldn't even entertain stayin in an
apartment somewhere you would just book
into local hold in a Travelodge or
whatever premier Reina whatever it was
so you wouldn't even look at booking
comm to look for apartments or you just
booked into a local hotel that is what
happened hey or a B&B back then it moved
B&B and look at the way people shop the
way people shop differently the the
everything's online the world is moving
so fast if you want to keep up you have
to move your business to keep up
otherwise your business will fail and
this this is the thing you've seen all
across country like B&B owners they're
struggling to compete with service
accommodation because they're not
they're refusing to move with the times
and that's why you've seen so many
bed-and-breakfast for sale on Rightmove
there's there's thousands of them that
are just they're not profitable they're
not making any money and they're trying
to offload the trying to sell because
service accommodation which is the new
thing has come along the BMP owners have
not moved with the times and know
they're getting hip-hip and impacted so
for them investments are not good but to
see is but bite elates are dead is a
very blanket statement and I think it's
fear-mongering it's people that are
stuck in their ways of dinner old school
but babies for example they're in a
great position because they are they've
got these big properties with rooms and
they could very easily just systemize it
into a hands-off HMO highly cleaner
dorami they're in a great situation to
adapt but they don't it does that
because they just look
establish it so we do it's the same same
with same with singlet so by two let's
very much I'm not dead no really they
just changed like you said I think you
summed up really well the first the
first then tou said they're not dead but
they've changed and you're right you're
right well so what the lessons to take
away if you're if you're looking to
education I think education is super
super key always and it's not even that
complicated not what's not I mean the
crash course which is a free the first
day is about bites let's yeah since very
bright if you wanna do both lets you
don't need much training on a free day
and you can find out about about Bart
it's it's pretty it's pretty pretty easy
how do you know people don't know how to
do people people come to me all this all
the time like my friends and that oh and
you probably I'm thinking of buying this
and it's like and they're not yeah it's
pretty good isn't it it's like a tuned
in a 50 grand how do you know I'm a
couple two weeks score on a crash course
in Birmingham no in London London anyway
it was London it was the name oh yeah
blames Elsa Chelsea yeah that's it
so I run across square and on the on day
one I was doing the the whole find in
the deal online on there on the stage
and I done that I've actually put an
offer in that house yesterday
yeah the deal I found was that good it
was very very good so it's a property in
Warrington and it's it's a repossession
which is fine and but English it's worth
but eighty five thousand we've had offer
accepted at forty two and a half yeah
it's literally half it was on the market
for fifty and we've got it done at 42
foot so much money on price ins come
back about 13,000 for rifo should be
good yeah a bit on that I was up a new
porch yeah we're waiting to see so
offers been accepted but it's caught
it's our company layer a company sale
sorry
repossession so you could literally get
to completion and as a pillow and it
just Kate Kazan um however well we'll
see what happens but that's interesting
that we found out on day one of the
crash course I found that they wanted
the crash course and it's funny because
no matter what hundreds of people would
be in the room as so you I mean none of
i keeping all the opportunity jump on it
i said that who wants it and a few world
gave everyone the opportunity jump on it
no one to come up on it and I went for
what my life story and and I went up
viewed it we've had builders go out
we've priced it up numbers walk it what
we've all forward to be Warford and is
provisionally been accepted so let's
check up on that bombshell but right
it's now time for this
[Music]
welcome back guys and in the news this
week we have a city that has cat rent
rises for the next 5 years and my good
friend Russell will tell you more I mean
just just thinking for a minute
so can you imagine if that I was not in
London thank God but can you imagine if
that happened in London's just like
citywide you cannot raise the rents for
5 years it's quite interesting five
years a long time yeah a long long time
very strong Berlin so luckily it's not
it's not it's not in the UK so you want
to give me this noon time what you think
going on so the Berlin state cabinet
agrees a five-year rent freeze Blinn
state cabinet has agreed to file your
own freeze for five years - it's not
very well written is it this is on the
Guardian maybe I'll just read it wrong I
have I added five years in sorry to
counter the rising housing costs in the
German capital the city's left-wing
coalition government wants to freeze the
rents for the apartments built any
problem built before 2014 according to a
report by the German news agency DPA
only minority of Berliners owned their
homes or apartments and their rent has
been rising sharply in recent years
forcing amazing about side the city the
city had been a low-rent mecca for many
years after the fall of the Berlin Wall
in 1989 opened the gates to economically
depressed former communist Easter City
this gave rise to an influx of artists
and other seeking a more bohemian way of
life that's like crazy that they could
do that yeah but if you noticed it was
only on apartments at a pre 2014 so
anything new in him after 2014 it's not
covered by that how many properties do
you own after 2014
maybe out there there's maybe that's in
Seattle incentivize a new bill do you
not think it is but it's in a big city I
mean most its gonna already be there
isn't it yeah but that will be
incentivizing developments that maybe
that's what they're trying to do
so you can build a property and then you
can charge what the heck you want and
just trying to stop rent increases from
the sound of it who benefits the tenants
of Enderby yeah landlords don't benefit
well no of course not it's gonna stop
that it's good it's also gonna stop that
for the it's gonna stop that the house
prices from rising one's gonna want to
buy their now exactly having said that I
very rarely put the rents up on my on my
places you haven't put the rents up when
you're original the first house you were
bought ever know we've had this
conversation before the the same lady
let's lived there for like seven years
me I never put if they're still there I
never bought the rent up so with it
would it be that much of a problem
that's the thing think about it really
because if you've never perience up
that's just controlling the market isn't
it I never liked it when they do things
like that because it's like surely it's
just it's just stamping all over supply
and demand and it's it's very it's a
very for me as someone who's an
entrepreneur that believes in people
will pay what it's worth it's it's very
red tape yeah rolling isn't it it's it's
interesting that I wonder where I almost
communist type attitude it's like oh
we're gonna tell you how much your you
can rent your house up for I wonder
weird Berlin is on this the rents kill I
wonder if it's a naturally high place
anyway and used to be low but it's it
traditionally is low but it's gone up a
lot recently I'm wondering where in the
scale of like other German cities where
it stands with regards to rent because
if it's already quite high all the
didn't stop it went even higher so still
it may still be a good place to invest
yeah actually of cap because they could
extend that quite easily they could just
if they can do that what else are they
gonna do what how they allowed to do
that it's not it's like yeah who they
say the most governing body that is the
government and what I'm saying is but
the UK government's to around you to
Alastair Cunningham as a house
you've got to rent it out but no more
you can't put the rent upon that house
yeah yeah how would it work if I wanted
to do it into a hey g-man what happened
then you know would not be allowed
because technically the
we going up maybe who knows what I don't
like good thing is we don't invest in
Berlin so no but why don't like about is
the precedent yeah yeah over Germany
what was something doing over here well
it's in Europe isn't it so we're not
gonna have that problem as off well
first of November so we'll see yeah yeah
we will see actually as a good policy
who knows anyway it's interesting for
you got other knows it would love to
know what you think if you if you think
it's a good thing or a bad thing or if
you've got any opinions on it please
comment please do let us know but I
think it sucks as well so on that on
that terrible disappointment it's time
for this I guess it's time for the
questions and answers you're looking
very tall okay so if you if you ever
want to ask a question by the way
please go on the Facebook group property
investors with Samuel Leeds we tend to
do a Facebook live in there every now
and again where you can come on and ask
questions and then we answer the one
here okay so the first question is from
Steve bench hey Steve keep up the good
work
my question although it can vary in your
experience guys how many hours do you
think makes the best productive average
working day a week for a full-time
property investors cheese cheese it
depends how much you want to get out of
it I mean how quickly do you want to get
successful how quickly do you want to
get out of it out your job for instance
well I suppose he's put full-time
suppose he means so this this would
apply for property investor yeah job for
anything are you doing so if you if
you're running a business which in this
case of a lot versus the business how
how many hours a week would you spend on
it I would spend as much as possible
because that's that's just what I'm like
I like to make sure things with them
properly and I like give me a number
wouldn't it was a productive number see
I know people are say for example you
should work four hours a day yeah
because then you can go full out for
four hours
absolutely non-stop and then you can do
something out and if four hours absolute
non-stop is more productive than most
people's 9:00 time I completely agree
with you and the thing is I couldn't get
a time on it but because I'm always like
my life doesn't stop because of property
but the in property doesn't stop because
I my life
it's a mixer and a combiner so like some
of these I might spend all day doing
property and I might spend all day doing
whatever I've got to do then all these I
may not touch them and even think about
it but let's say you were thinking
yourself six four to six hours four to
six yeah yeah the thing is we both do
more than that this is not a question I
can answer to be quizzing you because he
wants to model it on someone find it I
said I spend seven days a week thinking
about houses thinking about property
thinking about my next move that's true
and I might not spend ten hours a day
doing it but instead of watching
EastEnders at night I'm looking and
thinking about and I'm strategizing
about problem strategizing about the
next event the next this the next that
so we're talking about such as always
I'm always thinking about properly in my
spare time so it's quite sad really that
I don't have I don't really have much of
a social life but that I choose this I
choose to be heavily involved in
probably property I choose to to get on
with it because I want to be super
successful in it yeah and if I've got to
spend loads of time doing it then I will
don't be that person that says oh yeah
I'm gonna do this and then literally
won't give it give it any time because
you'll never get anywhere on the map and
the map people that I said it sorry the
amount of people that I see that want to
become deal sorcerers and they want to
be really really good at property no
that's not invest and that's becoming a
property of entrepreneur but the market
type people that come to me said look I
want to find investors and I'm at great
how many networking events do you go to
and then when I went to once it's like
every couple of months I'm like well
that's rubbish you're never gonna build
a business doing that no so if you want
it you've got to get out there and
you've got to do it if you want to build
investors you get out then your net week
I would start small I don't think it's
all about consistency it's if you know
networking don't you go once go once a
week maybe same event every time yeah
what I always say for someone starting
out in property land normally to be fair
it is alongside their full-time job but
you want me to get a minimum of seven
hours a week yeah absolute minimum of
seven hours a week so if you want a
future full-time job and going all into
it personally my full-time job I work
like I'm similar I work all the time but
if you're gonna do if you're gonna be
doing it what a long side to me out
just allocate some time whatever you
think I don't there's a right or wrong
answer I don't either I think it depends
on how quick you want to go what's wrong
how much you've got on why is it wrong I
was joking huh
but instead of look just think about it
like every single morning like most
people wake up what's the first thing to
do apart from you what's the first thing
they do when you wake up in the morning
generally most people what was first in
the you know what's first and most will
do most people pick up the phone and
scroll through social media that is true
yeah they look at their phone right
don't be rude they looking at their
phone that's that's true they probably
spent half an hour in the bed looking at
their phone at night this probably spent
and I want to have to us scroll through
social media so instead of doing that
scroll through right move
scroll through Gumtree find leads find
deals scroll through networking events
just used social media bar for a better
use next question please
this is of you in disguise Alexander
Cunningham ahaha this is your long-lost
brother hi guys absolutely love your
podcast is your bro no I don't have a
clue who is I genuinely don't just quit
one for you is there any way I can get a
mortgage at the age of 17 up in Scotland
or hat do I have to wait till I'm 18
that's what you 18 legal you can't get
mortgage to you you can't get any
finance on anything whether it be a
credit card will it be alone will be
anything legally until you're 18
no it's crazy isn't it because you're
old enough to drive yeah old enough to
have children
yeah old enough to drink alcohol in a
pub or get a mortgage yeah hey we don't
make the rules we just have to play by
them so like 18 bro you mean Samuel got
round it by by getting in use me for the
first one or the second one but you my
stepdad used he brought you into the
deal and you were you both done the deal
but he yeah yeah so you could
potentially dude you're 17 years old man
and get out there get work get get
meeting people and get along to seminars
networks events you get training again I
would say no could you rent
you're entering into legal contract you
can't rent menu 17 I would say no cuz
you renting her into a legal contract
all that come on how can you not rent
you 17 because what like people move out
at 16 well maybe I'm wrong but I
personally would say no until you're 18
because you're not legally maybe it's
maybe I'm getting out as you're 17 when
are you 18 can't be that far away make
sure you're out networking get to know
people you can do so I was ready for
when you're 18 but being a mind you
probably not get a buy to let mortgage
until you're 21 so bear that in mind
unfortunately Daniel Roberts hi guys
good stuff do you think that buy-to-let
can be hands-off with a management team
in a shorter time than other strategies
such as HMO service accommodation I
would say yes much easier because it's
just 110 and and generally us a single
that probably is easier to rent an HMO
and it's less problem so I and she / as
well most single late people are only
10% you can negotiate lower than that
but generally it's 10 percent yeah so
yeah I think yeah absolutely this is
from Ibrahim Odin when trying to secure
when to rent HMO deals what is the best
way to approach an agent I usually phone
a skiff the LAN was open to a corporate
that type of agreement and and then find
a lot of them said they need to ask the
landlord and Nellie about to me or
they're just not interested
do I need more explanation or should I
be adopting a different initial approach
that's a question for you as your your
it your area so rent around HMO deals I
would say it's it's easier to stay clear
from your traditional highest rate
letting agents you know off people have
a right move and you you're better off
keeping a similar approach master a
corporate agreement but speaking to you
say landlords off places like gum tree
and open rent and some of the agencies
on there they're much smaller agencies
much more flexible to to doing this sort
of deal only the you know the new
traditional estate agents so approach is
similar but yeah just just just don't
just go to smaller agencies and
landlords direct yeah do you know I've
just sent a lot of messages on and
Gumtree
and some
I'm working with somebody to find a lot
of deals for them and in and around
London and we've just sent out like 60
messages and we've had nine responses so
far it's pretty good yeah not bad
so just slips 60 messages we little one
line or one line screen percent yeah a
lot one line script properties that meet
match the criteria we're looking for
and we've had nine messages come back
this morning saying yeah we're open to
conversations give us a call on this
discuss so I've got a lot of phone calls
to make this afternoon trends get these
deals secured for the investor I'm
working with it a minute so yeah Gumtree
is the way forward for these sort of
things because you're direct a vendor
and you were a mixture of apartments and
HMOs yeah all right that's one advice
for a seventeen-year-old wanting to
become a deal sorcerer get yourself
along for the crash course learn about
it learn how to find good deals learn
how to find investors get your terms and
conditions correct and in place get all
your legal paperwork in place get
compliance in place make sure your trade
and legally compliant and ethically find
deals find investors match them up
create paperwork get paid boom track and
move on so they they matter as simple as
that as simple as that
well guys thanks ever so much for tuning
in to this week's show we are back next
Saturday at 7 p.m. please don't forget
to listen you can hear us on iTunes on
Spotify you can please do tune in and we
look forward to seeing you next week
cool guys thanks see ya
[Applause]
Oh